I hope you enjoyed thinknig about this question.
And I also hope you came up with something
resembling the right answer. Now overall you should
have gathered from all this information that a genetic
susceptibility is prominent for type two diabetes here.
Remember, a higher heritability value, anything over 0.5 indicates
a larger variance between the monozygotic and dizygotic twins.
Anything over 0.5 indicates something that's more genetically influenced.
Anything less than 0.5 would be more environmental.
We also have information from our monozygotic, dizygotic twin
concordances. Notice that we have from 70 to 90%
for monozygotic. And something significantly less for the dizygotic
twins. Again, this is indicative of a genetic component.
We even know, from our GWAS study, that there
are about 50 genetic factors influencing the trait. Now,
each one has a small effect, but that doesn't
mean it's any less genetic. It just means that
we have a lot of genetic factors contributing a
small amount individually. So given this explanation, I want
you to tell me. Look at your answer from the
question. How satisfied are you with your own answer
on a scale from one to five with one
not being at all satisfied and five being completely
satisfied. I want to know how you think you did.